you
if you've ever seen the matrix or played
a game like The Sims you're familiar
with the idea of simulated realities
humanity as a species has always been
interested in the idea that maybe
everything is not as it seems
perhaps reality is an illusion or in
more recent years perhaps we're living
in some super advanced computer
simulation but if what we can see and
experience is all we know how could we
possibly determine whether or not our
reality is real could we actually be
living in a simulation and if so what
does that mean for Humanity
if we look back to 1972 and the release
of pong then compare it to something
like battlefield 1 today we can see just
how far computing technology has come in
the past 45 years the amazing thing
about computing power is that it doesn't
grow in a linear fashion it grows
exponentially doubling roughly every two
years this trend is called Moore's law
Moore's law has caused many to speculate
just how advanced computers can get as
we get closer and closer to
photorealistic video games and virtual
reality the ability to make more
immersive simulations will come with it
the rapid growth of computing power and
efficiency has sparked the question what
if there are advanced civilizations with
computers powerful enough to simulate
the entire universe all the way down to
the molecular level sufficiently
advanced computers could program their
sims to feel like their conscious
generate false memories emotions and
sensory data in short the Sims would be
aware of their own existence but
completely oblivious to the fact that
their reality isn't real at all the idea
of digital realities is the basis for
what's called the simulation argument
the simulation argument brainchild of
philosopher Nick Bostrom suggests that
in the future posthuman technologically
mature civilizations will have enormous
computing power and would have the
ability to run what he calls ancestor
simulations meaning high fidelity
simulations of human life that would be
indistinguishable from reality to the
simulated ancestors the argument
proposes that one of three possibilities
must be true option one civilizations
that have potential to become capable of
running ancestor simulations go extinct
before they reach that point option two
civilizations that have reached
technological maturity and could run
ancestor simulations have no desire to
do so or option 3 almost all existing
civilizations with human level
experience are living in a simulation ok
that all sounds a bit strange let's
start from the beginning
option one suggests that running
ancestor simulations could be possible
but some calamitous event prevents any
civilization from reaching that point
this event could be an asteroid impact
nuclear fallout or more likely since
we're talking about the far future
disaster caused by some new technologies
such as self-replicating nanobots now if
so much as one civilization reaches
technological maturity we can rule out
option 1 as a possibility leaving only
options 2 and 3 so save the technology
to run these simulations is widely
available to advanced civilizations
option to suggest that these
civilizations might choose not to run
them the most likely explanation for
such a choice is for ethical reasons if
they can simulate emotions and
sensations then that means their Sims
could experience pain and suffering if
however even one civilization chooses to
run a simulation then we can rule out
option 2 as a possibility that leaves us
with only option 3 or what's commonly
referred to as the simulation hypothesis
if a post human civilization can run one
of these massive simulations then it
stands to reason that they could run
several for hundreds even thousands if
multiple civilizations did it the
simulated realities could number in the
millions or more with that number of
simulated realities it would suggest
that our own reality is more likely to
be a simulation rather than an original
civilization on its way to technological
maturity ok that's an interesting
thought but it sounds pretty crazy right
surely no one actually believes we're
living in a computer world well that's
not exactly the case Nick Bostrom
believes that there is a significant
chance somewhere between 20 and 50
percent that we do indeed live in a
simulated reality Elon Musk one of the
most visionary entrepreneurs of future
technology is almost certain that we're
just programs but how do we know for
sure you're probably familiar with
Plato's allegory of the cave which
describes a scene not entirely
dissimilar to a simulated reality in the
story people have been chained to a rock
in a cave their whole lives all they can
see is a rock wall straight in front of
them behind them figures pass in front
of a fire casting shadows on the wall
these shadows are the prisoners reality
it's all they can see so it's all they
know if we've grown up in a simulated
reality and everything around us is
false but it's all we know there's
really no way to discern whether our
reality is true but for the sake of
argument let's assume that one lone sim
figured out that the world around him
was a
Malaysian what would happen well if
you've ever played a modern video game
you probably already know the answer the
architects of this simulation would just
load a previous save and make sure the
sim doesn't have that moment of
realisation again okay say we do live in
a simulated reality how would that
affect the world around us well if we
think of our entire universe running on
a computer we would understand that it
requires an enormous amount of computing
power so to save on RAM or whatever the
future equivalent is the architects
could have high fidelity and low
fidelity portions of our simulated
universe so if we were aware that we
lived in a simulation any
self-interested sim should strive to be
noteworthy or risk being relegated to a
low memory or non conscious portion of
the simulation things get really
interesting when we consider the nature
of the universe itself if you've ever
tried running a graphics intensive game
on an old computer you know that it
becomes choppy or slow because the
computer can't keep up now think about a
black hole an object with incalculable
mass and gravity spinning at tremendous
speed and what happens in the vicinity
of such massive objects time slows down
general relativity itself operates in a
manner that mimics a computer trying to
economize on memory usage then you can
consider what would happen if hundreds
of years down the line in our simulated
reality humans developed the technology
to create their own simulated universe
at that point the strain on the original
architects computer could prove too much
and crash our entire reality or that
could be the end game the architects
could just be letting our simulation
play out to see how their ancestors
developed the necessary technology to
run such advanced simulations as our own
technology becomes more and more
sophisticated
we march toward an inevitable moment of
life or death when we finish the machine
capable of running an ancestor
simulation we're one flick of a switch
from narrowing down the three options of
the simulation argument to two when we
launch the simulation the world could
keep spinning or game over in the end
the simulation argument depends upon the
computational theory of the mind which
proposes that consciousness is simply
natural information processing if it is
then the human brain can be simulated by
a computer or artificial intelligence if
it's something more then a computer may
never be able to simulate human
consciousness no matter how advanced
it's all very fascinating to think about
and while many people claim to have seen
a glitch in the matrix as they're often
called it's impossible to discern for
sure whether I real
is original with our current level of
technology but just in case go do
something interesting so you don't get
deleted if you'd like to learn more
about the simulation argument and other
ideas check out the links in the
description make sure to subscribe if
you haven't already and follow second
thought on your favorite social media do
we live in a simulation share your
thoughts in the comments below if you
enjoyed this video click here to watch
my video on artificial intelligence or
click here to watch all my videos thanks
for watching and I'll see you in the
next video